and the Whitehouse coronavirus task
force are holding near daily press
briefings and they're watched by
millions of Americans so are they
helpful in providing pertinent
information or do they risk sending
mixed messages let's bring in Fox News
media analysts have workers a host of
media buzz and I get good-cop bad-cop I
totally get that I also know that right
now everybody is hanging on the
president's every word how he says a
syllable what he's looking like when he
says at the tone with which he says it
what do you think well the president was
bragging about the ratings for these
daily briefings but they are absolutely
necessary at a time of such intense
national anxiety they're helping the
president politically with rising
approval of how he's handling the crisis
but the problem is the phrase you use
the mixed messages sometimes between the
president's more reassuring approach and
the dire warnings of his top medical
experts which leads the confusion and
generates a lot of stories about
division in the administration but that
changed yesterday Dana when president
seemed sobered by the warnings he got
from Anthony Falchi and dr. Debra Berg
so you showed earlier saying that if all
the restrictions were relaxed as many as
2 million people could die the president
repeated that figures 16 times at
yesterday's presser yeah he's really
trying to drive that home for people I
also wonder just about the the offhand
you know spitballing the brains drawing
me like maybe we'll do this maybe we'll
do that such as the idea of the you know
the shutdowns in New York Connecticut in
New Jersey it turned out not to be the
case but people are listening to every
single word that he says you know Donald
Trump's governing style is that he
thinks out loud and so he may say you
know I may nominate somebody to the Fed
and if it's criticism he doesn't
nominate the person that's just the way
he rolls but in this situation it scared
a lot of people in the New York
tri-state area thought maybe I have to
get out if there's gonna be a quarantine
and I can't go visit family elsewhere in
that sort of thing
he got it brought strong criticism from
Governor Andrew Cuomo who's felt
blindsided because they just talked that
day and in the end the president didn't
do it and so it underscores your point
about how words matter in this
environment yes you always have to
choose them very carefully because the
most powerful person in the world as
everybody's listening Howie Kurtz thank
you so much good to see you